thank you yes
redemption is the word for 2021 right
brian
absolutely absolutely so this is your
magical place and i say magical because
everywhere it's just got so much energy
it's exactly what we
mean this year so right here you have
the
rep rebel room right now what's going on
so we have a rebel pass going on right
now so it's half boxing has strength
training
as you can see it's basically like a
nightclub the energy is ridiculous
people working out and strength on this
side
boxing on the left it's absolutely chaos
was a great workout
very instructor up there kind of like a
dj it's a great time
i did a little boxing during the season
during the show and
i was a little fired yeah
you know it's just one of those
adjustment things just sell different
types of masks that really help you out
for breathing but it's really breathing
exercise it actually has a little
intensity to the workout so what kind of
mask do you prefer
um something like you're wearing is
disposable it's easily breathable not
something like i'm wearing
we sell face shields and also chin masks
too which
are compliant as well and how are you
guys just you know making sure this is
safe for everybody in the community
yeah so as you see everything's socially
distanced we have six feet apart with
everybody we have spots blocked off
we're also adding barriers uh just
flying by all that
class all right you have no excuses no
excuse the time you're going for new
year's resolutions we've got three
classes all week talk more about that
but i want to show you more of what they
have to offer here because now we're
entering
the ride room which is one of my
favorite rooms here because i love to
spin
so what else do you guys offer besides
the rep rebel and now the ride
yeah yeah we have four different
modalities so rep rebel this is our spin
room so it's kind of like dancing on a
bike
and our third room is heat of fitness so
pilates boot camp and bar
everything's high intensity interval
training a lot of fun fitness night club
environment
i'm gonna go ahead and sit on this spin
bike you can have a seat on one too yeah
yeah
you guys will get warmed up i've got my
boxing gloves on and on the spin bikes
this is not what you suggest right now
yeah i think whatever you know okay so
what do you want to tell the viewers out
there who are starting their year off
obviously last year was pretty hard
really hard i can't say pretty it was
really hard really difficult and we're
still trying to get over the hump
yeah how can we start this year off
right yeah absolutely i think a lot of
people think of
fitness as a physical thing but it's
mainly mental right so really just
clearing your mind whatever your goals
are
it starts mentally and i think getting
in a fitness routine really helps you
with that
absolutely and is there any advice on
you know people feeling like this might
be too hard for them
yeah i mean we have classes from
beginner intermediate to advanced yeah
cycling especially can kind of go at
your own pace
we're welcome to basically everyone in
all levels and we kind of
we welcome that yeah that's awesome okay
so coming up next we're gonna go into
another room you guys have because
seriously you guys offer so much and
what i love about this place
can we can we give maria some some love
here look at her i love her energy
she loves the attention what i love
about redemption fitness is that you
guys can
you guys hit on so many different parts
of fitness
in one place yeah a lot of different
fitness tools just have one modality we
have all different modalities under one
roof
for one price and limited classes it
just helps you not to plateau and not
get bored and that's the name of the
game of fitness
definitely good advice heading into the
new year and um lastly but not least
guys free workout classes all week tell
them how they can do that yes our grand
openings all week through sunday january
10th check out our schedule redemption
fitness dot com you can book classes
online
book your bag book treadmill in advance
and come in for men's class you won't
get no routine
listen sign me up all right sign me up
back to you
henderson 2560 saint rose yes
i'll bring it back to you guys